[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cet ami que les spectateurs à votre
récepteur il n'est pas un dérangement
c'est bien l'escargot qui est là après
quatre rendez-vous remis fin mars avant
d'état le 26 avril raison d'état le 10
mai à lyon d'état le 23 mai à raison
d'état et oui mais il est là finalement
il est bien là avec toutes ces cases
toutes ces lumières et toutes ses dents
alors on l'applaudît très escarpée
[Applaudissements]
non deux premiers concurrents que nous
avons des sens parce qu'il faut lui
mettre en confiance
[Applaudissements]
paris 9e donc point beaucoup de chemin à
faire revenir ici sur ce quai de la
seine alors votre prénom monsieur grebot
claude votre prénom madame robot michel
votre armure robot 34 je ne demande
jamais subi des personnes de sexes n'est
pas
une distraction préférée un jeu beaucoup
le tarot et vous madame un gros mot je
n'aime pas le terme ça doit passer ça va
vous pourrez pas être enfin vos
professions respectives
programmeur-analyste pro l'analyse ça
veut dire je fais de la programmation
sur l'ordinateur
déjà quelqu'un de technologiquement très
évolués et vous
je suis rédac tricherie dit avoir
conduit alors on sait à qui on aura à
faire face jeudi faut absolument que
notre règlement à la moindre faille
alors jetons attend un petit coup d'oeil
sur ce saut cet escargot il comporte 20
une gaze et vous allez disposer de
d'écouté pour aller de case en case à
chacune de ces cases correspond une
chanson ou extraits de chansons et
l'épreuve s'y rapportant plus ou moins
alors les tarifs maintenant si vous
tombez sur une case rose l'épreuve
bosses enfants une bleue 200 francs une
jaune quarantaine deux c'est bien normal
300 enfants vous pouvez par ailleurs
améliorer sérieusement votre score vos
tarifs en mettant avant chacune monsieur
madame gros bourg avant chacun écoute
des sept plaques de 500 francs comme au
casino voyez sur la case de votre choix
signale au deuxième tour lorsque vous
serez passer par la case mate et une
vous aurez le droit à une
deux mille fois alors maintenant je vais
vous présenter nos invités car en effet
et le vent joue un rôle très important
nos invités à chacune des épreuves vous
allez pouvoir de désigner un de ses
invités pour venir répondre à vos côtés
à votre place ou vous aider
c'est vous dire avec quelle soit nous
les avons choisis et c'est avec quel
soin nous allons maintenant les
accueillir par exemple et les frères
ennemis l'innovation
vous avez le courage de monsieur dame
grelet
grand gaube avis et changer sans avoir à
faire tout et pour votre défense aurait
absolument à leurs côtés nous l'avons
également réunis parce qu'ils sont
complices dans un film on ne parlerait
au cours de votre parcours tout d'abord
gérard jugnot des bronzés
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes très contents d'être là au
nom de la france
bon
je ne dirais pas grand chose sur olivier
lejeune parce que vous le verrez
constamment il est mon complice pour
inventer tous les jeux
voilà monsieur jean louis blaise qui
n'en peut plus de voir raconter une
blague
[Applaudissements]
la musique idir chauffeur taxi auprès
parmi les 250 m mais pourquoi le manque
de francs 50
ans maintenant le complice et ami claude
roy désir celui d'areva
avec ce vent cuisine heures
deux invités d'honneur et nous allons
lui réserver l'eau assure toute
particulière roland magdane
que vous allez découvrir maintenant
monsieur madame groupe regardez ce temps
va jouer un grand rôle tout au long
repas car nous avons beaucoup de jeu où
il y aura peut-être des erreurs
possibles avec des rattrapages possible
alors monsieur gros bobos je crois que
là vous aurez un grand rôle à jouer
d'ailleurs nous allons monsieur andré
veilleux neutre
[Applaudissements]
un peu sa part été et ne sera prêté dans
chacune de démission par le rex club à
paris où vous pouvez d'ailleurs monsieur
propos chaque soir les entraîner car il
paraît que depuis que président reagan
envoyé ce tour en france il fait fureur
et le rex club ne désemplit pas alors
pour vous donner
oui
alors vous vous placez votre plaque pour
la première fois comme si nous étions au
casino de l'esca
quelques a choisi ses mots le 4 le cadre
évidemment vous ne pouvez pas aller plus
loin que le 6 puisque noter le comporte
que si j alors attention premier coup d
et bonne chance monsieur m'a l'amour
[Musique]
le
et bien valérie s'il vous plaît sur un
casque bleu devant vous quinze bleu donc
d'une valeur de 200 francs nous allons
maintenant évidemment comme cette case
comme toutes les cases correspondantes
la chanson accueillir justement l'invité
d'honneur la deuxième invitée d'honneur
dans la place était resté libre karen
cheryl a raison graphique celle ci
[Applaudissements]
là la neige gelée les enfants
m
ans
[Musique]
une
un peu hors jeu
c'est gagné
performant
du cher
ce sera
et la musique tu joues pas c'est même
encore un peu plus
j'adore le coeur
[Musique]
si
la musique
s'il est encore
dans le car radio branchée sur les
patins
là dans les cieux d'autres toujours
[Musique]
qui aime les secrets
le tard
[Musique]
qui m
tiens
[Musique]
un peu comme je suis
moi pas toute la
duzert
cela
[Musique]
ilan abc
il a dans le coeur
a dû ranger sur l'équateur
[Musique]
mais je vous dis bien si il aime les
plages de normandie
si le soleil mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur et madame drobo concurrents nos
amis tu es bien placé à ce premier rang
comme dans quatre à côté dans le mac dan
alors très vite de cette première
épreuve mais si madame brobo inspiré de
la chanson de karen si si cela dit
monsieur globaux comme c'est un jeu où
il risque d'y avoir des erreurs vous
allez remplacer monsieur b sur le
taureau car c'est à vous que membre vous
fera appel pour vous rattraper j'espère
que vous êtes un bon cavalier pas du
tout ça se présente bien alors attention
qui choisissez vous vous avez droit à
deux aides roland magdane et
puis maurice biraud maurice n'y a rien
dans ce que l'on tient ses sbires google
a bien sûr un
bon bout de temps vous donne à parler
très fort parce que vous n'avez pas de
micros je vous dit
si je
sors mon papier de papa 515 bovine
alors si je me dis il a perdu 52 kg
bah il faut qu'il dépose une plainte
c'est dennis causso serait bien des miss
qui je redis les jumelles étaient en
vogue en 1981 les jumelles
attention ces cinq seulement d'achat
pour être
beau attention
léger mal c'était denise fabre marlène
jobert
c'est également du taux les dix
premières secondes pas monsieur gros mot
allons-y passera gentil je vous prends
même ce gros con plus vous avez un
véritable position de super preuves
ailleurs les masseurs
cochabamba des rides staps a servi les
eaux là ils ont été très dur j'ai
l'impression que le temps ne vous aime
pas monsieur très vite si je vous dit
écoutez la différence ben français mais
ici je vous dis elkabbach lequel là
pourquoi et le cab h au canada tombés
d'accord
non je marchais
we7 1807 m le monde women mona lisa
mais aussi à la sainte bible est
difficile les honneurs drague oui non
et diverses et les homards
à demain si vous le voulez bien
évidemment
et parce que monsieur
oui moi je devrais je me disais que j'ai
fait ce qu'il fallait démontrer voilà
même du pif abbas ira n'offre
actuellement oui 19h55 tous les
mercredis le l'autre nous tous nous
sommes avec toi vas y vas vite hongrie
les danaïdes non non le tout noté ddd
démosthène non non dieu jaloux
donc ornicar oui c'est bien vrai ça
c'est bien vrai qui dit ça c'est bien
vrai strasbourg
attention attention ça c'est bien vrai
c'était pas prévu au programme tout en
grâce et dernière question est est-ce
parce que c'est vraiment le jeu procure
à sauver la mise venez vous tenez vous
bien ses boutons histoire de l'aidant
enfin les 200 francs par le reste
attention fait bientôt
et
si elle a bondi de repas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pire on vous quittez vous laisser le
sucre pour reprendre sa place en ce qui
nous concerne pas ce que nous aura
cependant nous ne donnons plus de 4 me
disant simplement à bientôt pour votre
deuxième couteau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous bonsoir monsieur
madame gros bobos soient roland magdane
que vous ne pouvez plus quitté
apparemment madame robot vous avez bien
fait vous allez voir pourquoi dans
quelques secondes alors nous en sommes à
votre deuxième étape non sans vous
rappeler que hier vous avez réussi votre
première épreuve et que vous gagnez
actuellement 200 francs bon alors nous
passons donc au 2e coûté non sans avoir
au préalable en vous rappelant que vous
étiez tombé sur la case beyer donc la
casse de leur partant de la case 2 vous
placez cette plaque de 500 francs sur
une des six suivantes laquelle le 5 le
ca donc si tout à l'heure grâce aux
coups de thé le total des dépenses la
case de départ nous amène sur l'a 4 5
vous avez 500 francs de plus la case 5
est en elle une quarantaine de saffré
vis en france je vous le souhaite de
tout coeur envoyé ce dès
nous souhaitons à trois bien sûr
monsieur
doussain et dans les rues
sur la base numéro 5 et roger l'agro
nous annonce la hauteur du cou eh bien
ce sont franck 1 300 800 faut quand même
pas triché voilà et bien au sujet des
genres eh bien nous allons maintenant
grâce à cette case non pas une chanson
nous attend mais un sketch et pas
n'importe quel sketch puisque si celui
de monsieur roland magdane et ce sont
les organes
allons bon jour ici l'estomac vient d'y
creux capter ce come back at elle à
table ici le cerveau message reçu mais
si les organes en place à l'eau à la
bouche vous m'entendez je vous donne
tant mieux attention je vous signale au
passage de 9 du royaune et
bonjour bonjour ici le voir comment l
ennemi lyonnais les à elle en moins de
trois jours encore une bonne chance à
tout ça
bonjour bonjour ici le substrat langues
j'aimerais parler au paquet de nerfs si
c'est possible
ouais c'est pas été dérobés
bon ok ce qui peut te défie ce pas que
de nerfs
bonjour à toutes et si nous sommes unis
6 hamida
alors il confirmera pas c'est le cas du
joueur c'est une horreur
c'est du poisson mais bichon on va
encore se prendre déjà être la gorge
mais j'en ai marie jolin
bonjour ici le foie comment une le
poisson
ipu m'oblige nuit
alors oui oui ici la dent creuse mais
j'aime bien des défis de haïku là est ce
que pourrait demander à la langue de me
donner un coup de main impossible la
langue est occupée elle colle un timbre
à
stopper m'envoyer un doigt en dépannage
j'ouvre la boîte tout de suite alors le
bot dans le nez pour des salons de la
bouche
beaucoup beaucoup et me fit le cheveu
sur la langue j'aimerais par lé goutte
au nez trop tard vient de tomber
attention ici la bouche j'ai une
mauvaise nouvelle à vous annoncer la
dent creuse et vient de tomber elle ne
s'est pas mieux avec nos fils de l'art
et qu on joue à 10,6 me ses amygdales
écoutez les dans là-haut les [ __ ]
prépa machel et peu non on vient voir
passer une nouille de 20 cm sans cette
histoire
bonjour bonjour ici le foie comment
elles sont une ouïe elle tue ma biche
plus inouï ça commence à bien faire je
renvoie toutes les marchandises
attention attention ici le cerveau
plantier où tous ça remonte
[Applaudissements]
voilà ce qu est ce qui fera date et bien
c'est bien sûr ce sketch qu'il avait sur
les mêmes
sites et warner très connu le tibia très
bien de la cité mois un muscle près
connu le bis est faible maintenant si tu
es moi un air très connus sous les ponts
de paris
on dépense alors que une époque de la
plus haute importance à temps monsieur
un gros bonnet près riom 800 francs
alors cette épreuve bien sûr est inspiré
du sketch dont l'enac dame mais tout
d'abord nous allons avant de vous
soumettre à cette leçon d'anatomie je
voudrais que vous désignez parmi tous
nos amis celui qui va vous remplaciez
monsieur propos sur le taureau en cas
d'erreur
vous êtes tous partants
rien n'est qu'un pas l'air d'accord
vous monsieur moto vous allez suivre
l'escargot pendant que j'ai joué c'est
parti et de votre équipe et va vous
rattraper en cas d'erreur car en effet
je vais maintenant vous énoncer des noms
des différentes parties de votre
individuel à chaque fois vous devez
instantanément d'indiquer l'endroit du
corps concernés par exemple monsieur
mêmes propos si je vous dis coeur
alors ensemble et d'un commun accord
vous mettez la main sur le coeur alors à
chaque erreur
gérard je ne peux pas proposer à des
accords ça va il prend son temps pour
monter tir à l'attention c'est pourquoi
the fall tibia
faut-il un coup il a mis les autres
coûts et bah
oui
raison évoquée est que baby
c'est la première erreur on passe dessus
allez les reins larynx estomac biceps
embolie ben
mince
alors en fait tu te rappelles je crois
que c'est gérard jugnot qui va en faire
un petit peu sur le taureau
oui c'est parti pour dix secondes donner
vie à vos chers amis vous voyez
non
[Musique]
m
hachez la queue à la fête du taureau
ça
il se croit une corridor lui a déjà
donné l'accueil
[Applaudissements]
nous poursuivons 13 ans je attention
colons colons colons vite vite vite que
l'on iris
oui clavicule appendice omoplates
mollet
duodénum
non les gens tirent fémur
fémur bon d'accord gérard gillioz on
peut pas être gentil éternellement le
fémur j'espère qu'il va pas seul brisé
très bien deux camps
et là nous n'aurions pour 15 secondes à
la même vitesse bien sûr il n'a pu que
pour ce prix là c'est très grave
attention
vous savez je monte que ce toro fait
fureur concernant l'ex un peu d'ailleurs
les nous entraider ce que d'ailleurs
bizarre
sur 9 rb
libellé de cette position inconfortable
à temps on les utilise cette dernière
qu'est-ce que
l'auditeur
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout à fait de circonstance par le
coccyx
ensuite c'est fontanel oui oui d'accord
on voit que vous avez des enfants rotule
côte
astragale
poumons comme d'eustache thorax talon
d'achille le nez le coude le menton la
nuque le poignet la cheville la colonne
vertébrale le nombril les cheveux
l'orteil le pouce et la longue vous le
tir et
j'ai
très vite nous allons immédiatement
demandé monsieur même cru bon de nous
placer la plaque de 500 francs sur un
autre numéro alors que nous étions roger
lago rester sur quelle case nous étions
sur la sec mais d'ores et déjà monsieur
un bonbon ont gagné 1000 francs
alors sorti
[Applaudissements]
contreplaqué vite
allons la plaque de 500 francs mais vous
rêvez du dos valérie le nef le nov sur
le neuf attention renvoyer le thé
en fait il faudra
4.47 café
là que dix
plaques d'une valeur de 100 francs
combien reste-t-il monsieur georges
garié notre réalisateur parce que le jeu
maintenant qui va nous permettre
d'accueillir philippe chatel était
étroitement lié avec le temps qu'il nous
reste deux minutes alors en fait il y
aura une petite conclusion 20 secondes
après le jeu alors pour la somme de
combien roger lago 100 francs et bien
pour la somme de 100 francs vous allez
devoir arrêter cette chanson de philippe
chatel qui précisément parle un peu
d'escargots un certain moment à une
minute temps bien entendu vous me
remettez vos montres comme notre ami
comme notre ami roland magdane montre t
poignet il en a pas parce qu'on sait
jamais avec lui il aurait pu vous
soufflez à une minute trente vous
arrêter et philippe chatel il est temps
de dix secondes avant dix secondes après
c'est gagner quand même je voudrais
mettre certains lui le temps ce qui
[Musique]
je voudrais partir
dre m'enfuir sans rien laisser
tout quitter
[Musique]
quitter
important
[Musique]
y a des jours et c'est pas
thibault
[Musique]
oubliez ce qui me gêne en main
ce qui va
mieux que ce qu'ils font jamais ce
qu'ils disent
j'emporterai
échec bouge
qui tu es
tout quitter
[Musique]
sur le
ah ouais
voilà
si tu sors
ce qui
[Musique]
deux schémas stop stop alors nous allons
connaître le verdict en régie à quelques
secondes exactement été arrêtés la
chanson till i chatel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aussi mes yeux de rebond bram où ils se
rendent plus nous en sommes à combien au
moment nous ne séparons 1100 francs et
bien à votre prochain côté et toujours
sans date si dieu le permet bonsoir à
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir à tous bonsoir à
tous nos amis et surtout bonsoir
monsieur madame gros bon alors nous en
sommes à votre troisième étape 3 des
rendez-vous mais déjà au quatrième coup
de dés seraient peut-être d'ailleurs
bien parce que quand on raconte un peu
d'une nouvelle émission le raconte un
peu trop vite et moi qui suis joueur
habitué des casinos est peut-être bon de
préciser comment se déroule ce fameux
système de cette petite plaque de 500
francs que je vais demander à valérie de
bien vouloir apporter et la montrer aux
caméras en effet cette plaque de 500
francs c'est un plus
chaque fois que vous désignez une case
et que vous mettez cette plaque de 500
francs dessus et que grâce au système de
notre jeu 2d vous tomber dessus ses 530
gagner en plus du prix d'un de la case
c'est compris alors attention sur quelle
case pour ce quatrième coup de dés
allez-vous mettre cette plaque de plus
vous êtes actuellement sur la case
combien monsieur lago numéro 10 10 alors
vous avez de 10 à 16 dépêchons-nous vite
vlv use 12-12 oui parce que vous savez
que rien ne va plus et comme au casino
alors si grâce à ce côté nous sortons à
2,10 plus de 12 vous aurez donc 530 plus
sur cette case qui vont déjà 300 francs
puisque c'est une quarantaine de
renvoyer le d
à 2 de toutes nos forces nous a besoin
de toutes nos forces eh bien le 5
10 et zinjibar niveau supporters roger
lago wii devrait bien nous allons sur la
case casquette une case rose d'une
valeur de 100 francs à vous tombez
souvent sur les sang-froid mais pas de
chance mais enfin pour l'instant vous
n'avez pas encore perdu cette plaque car
vous avez qu au premier échec je vous la
reprend il faudra attendre la casse va
t'il pour en récupérer l'autre qui sera
d'ailleurs de mille fois pour l'instant
nous allons nous laisser bercer par un
film parle extraits de films en effet ce
film qui va nous permettre d'ailleurs de
saluer deux des interprètes de ce film
maurice biraud et gérard jugnot notre
cowboy de service hier et ce même si
vous permet de voir un extrait de
pourquoi pas nous
[Applaudissements]
de résister
recevoir les félicitations de tout le
monde et notamment de guérande cheryl
alors vous pouvez peut-être nous
expliqué maurice et gérard en deux mots
quel est ce film de michel bernie avec
aldo maccione et dominique l'avenant et
notamment avec vous deux en l'occurrence
racines quand on vient de voir on a
deviné mathieu est un catcheur et il
tombe amoureux de 7,17 libraires ce qui
était absolument pourquoi pas nous c'est
un couple vraiment qu'ils aient pas fait
au départ pour s'entendre et là elle a
assisté à un match et vous savez les
catcheurs quelque sorte du riz et il est
tombé sur la malheureuse lavanant il lui
a cassé la jambe et vient s'excuser sur
les indications de son de son imprésario
et je suis l'arbizon film de larry qu'il
arrive beaucoup d'aventurés on ne pourra
pas dire que ce film ne casse rien
et le ring le propre de l'homme
pourquoi pas nos michel bernines avec
cette distribution au combien
sympathique que nous venons d'entre eux
voient et bien vous allez continuer à
faire preuve d' ailleurs de vos talents
de comédien voulez vous vous levez
monsieur maurice biraud monsieur gérard
jugnot
monsieur andré bgi monsieur jean louis
blaise nous avons besoin de vous pour la
première étape de cette rencontre qui
vont comporter trois années vous allez
avoir à deviner des quatre répliques qui
vont vous être offertes par ces quatre
comédiens celle qui est exactement la
bonne et en plus vous devrez nous dire à
quel film ne l'avons emprunter mais pour
cela je voudrais d'ailleurs que ces
quatre répliques vous soit donnée à vous
madame grebot alors voulez-vous aller
sur l'escargot car tout à l'heure ce
sera peut-être monsieur gros pot qui
devra donner la réponse à la dation
premier séducteur jean louis blaise tas
de belles mirettes tu sais embrasse-moi
deuxième séducteur andré bézu t'as
d'beaux yeux tu sais embrasse moi
ils en profitent ils profitent de la
situation refuser le monsieur troisième
c'est victor maurice biraud à une belle
bouche tu sais
regarde-moi
quatrième réplique par gérard jugnot un
beau regard c'est dommage que le droit
ne soit pas exactement comme le gauche
mais embrasse pont quand même
voilà alors maintenant monsieur
gros bobos vous allez remplacer un de
ses séducteurs et vous allez prononcer à
madame gros pot votre épouse la phrase
que vous croyez la bonne en la regardant
bien sûr les yeux dans les yeux et nous
allons voir si vous avez trouvé la bonne
réplique alors je vous écoute
beaux yeux tu sais
embrassement
alesi bras
[Applaudissements]
pardon quai des brumes bravo alors vous
restez sur l'escargot monsieur globaux
c'est madame robot qui vient s'asseoir
pour écouter maintenant alors deux vamps
devant pl qui vont se succéder devant
devant votre époux madame grebot pour
donner quatre autres répliques d'un film
célèbre tout d'abord la première vente
je crois que c'est sophie des
atmosphères
est-ce que j'ai une tronche d'atmosphère
à karachi
atmosphère atmosphère est ce que j'ai
une bobine d'atmosphère troisième sophie
atmosphère est ce que j'ai une gueule
d'atmosphère et enfin la quatrième série
tient
atmosphère est ce que j'ai l'air
d'atmosphère ce soit des atmosphères
bien agréable en attendant madame gros
bon maintenant c'est à vous d'aller
prononcé auprès de monsieur drobo la
bonne de ces quatre répliques karen
cheryl va vous laisser la place et vous
adresser à votre époux atmosphère
atmosphère est ce que j'ai une gueule
d'atmosphère
dans les accords du sang
[Applaudissements]
hôtel du nord aux rameaux alors il n'ya
plus que monsieur grands mots qui reste
car maintenant quatre docteurs vont se
pencher sur son cas
avec c'était au scope en main et tout
d'abord le premier de ces docteurs c'est
le docteur teddy qui va venir vous
adresser une première des quatre
répliques et il n'y a qu'une toujours
qu'une d'eaubonne 3 de fausses
voilà
alors ça vous gratouille ou ça vous
chatouille bon la première des
consultations et terminer voici celle
d'andré bézu
alors
où ça vous embrouilles drôle de manière
de traiter ses clients lui le troisième
docteur c'est notre ami maurice biraud
alors ça vaut très fouillés ou savoga
rouille
et enfin le quatrième de nos praticiens
ce monsieur andré gaillard qui réclame
son stéthoscope parce qu'il a besoin de
prendre le coeur de monsieur globo alors
c'était comme une grenouille qui vaut
barbouille ou autre et fouilles
voulez vous choisir de ces quatre
curieux docteur celui qui à votre avis
est le plus indiqué pour avoir donné la
bonne réplique ça vous gratouille ou ça
vous chatouille et lequel était ce
qu'il a dit
voilà c'était le dr s'est dit bravo et
dans quel film technotes voilà bravo
[Applaudissements]
parce que je vais prendre de bonnes
connaissances cinématographiques très
vite calé le score j'ai bien bravo un 4
sur 4 un sans faute est toujours en
route pour le grand chelem 12 130 brown
avec une multiplication par 5 karen
cheryl ne va pas quitter la médecine ni
le corps médical car elle va nous parler
d'un acte docteur qu'elle considère
mentent en effet d'acteurs qui qui
certainement être à villa à l'afro
nanterre enfin c'est ce que nous allons
voir en écoutant cette chanson qui fut
d'ailleurs un si grand succès sur
laquelle nous séparons en disant à
bientôt monsieur même gros pour votre
cinquième côte des bons soirs
[Musique]
bonsoir bonjour à tous bon soir tous les
amis bonsoir anne et du public bonsoir
monsieur madame brobo nous vous avons
quitté hier en compagnie de carême c'est
avec elle que nous recommençons cette
émission on seuil de 7 ce quatrième
étape
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai besoin d'eux
oh
honteux
sos
[Musique]
docteur docteur j'ai un petit truc qui
va pas tous les matins à 7 heures je
fais pipi tous les matins à 7 heures
mais ça y est c'est très bien ça pour
vous êtes très bien réglé il ya un
inconvénient je ne me réveille pas
buteur
renault
serious man brdo et notamment votre
cinquième côté alors on va rappeler la
situation parce que je crois qu'elle
devient assez intéressante et ils sont
actuellement à quelqu'un me roger à la
15 15 4 coûte des quatre bons coups de
dés et une somme de 12 100 francs au
crédit de monsieur madame autrement donc
sur le chemin du grand chelem n'y a pas
eu d'erreur et vous êtes à la casse
tiens c'est à dire si vous faites ainsi
arriver à la casse 21 alors la cause 21
c'est une case sur lequel il faut quand
même que je m'arrête quelques secondes
c'est une cause formidable parce que si
vous tombez en plein sur la cap 21 non
seulement on va vous donner une deuxième
plaque qui sera une plaque de 1000
francs mais en plus vous pourrez
repartir pour un deuxième tour
d'escargots d'où vous voudrez voiliers
et comme à chaque fois que vous passez
par la case 21 on vous donne une plaque
2000 font maintenant voyez ça vaut le
coup donc on va attendre avec impatience
que vous tombiez dans la case 21 cela
dit vous avez quand même car nous sommes
encore dans le premier tour toujours à
placer votre plaque de 500 francs sur
une case de votre choix ce plus 500
alors très vite votre choix 21 21 alors
là vous jouez le grand chelem
c'est-à-dire le grand jeu alors là vous
jouer sur tous les tableaux et bien
maintenant attention pour ce coup de dé
lancer le dé et tout le monde attend 1,6
[Musique]
il n'a manqué qu'un mais ce petit pois
va peser lourd cela dit nous allons sur
la case 20
et alors là on tombe véritable entre
charybde en scylla ben alors c'est une
carte glace en france et pas du tout
pareil cela dit faut le jouer c'est le
jeu c'est peut-être une case sur
laquelle vous allez trébucher parce que
ce n'est pas une case facile en effet
vous savez que car m karen cheryl est
toujours à la recherche de textes pour
ses chansons il se trouve que parmi nos
amis et un poète sait pas lequel
d'ailleurs qui a composé un poème
malheureux jouet l'oublier toutes les
rimes toutes les derniers tous les
derniers mots de série alors vous allez
monsieur gros beau parce que c'est une
épreuve vous allez devoir peut-être
rattrapé madame sur cette mer mieux
merveilleuse monture à cornes alors bon
courage monsieur lecavalier mal un gros
pot voulez vous choisir deux poètes pour
être à votre droite et votre gauche
karen cheryl sans aucune intention
politique à rennes
bien votre grosse du côté du coeur
maurice biraud maurice biraud aulas il a
beau avoir 100 ans participent et
séduisant
[Applaudissements]
allons-y eh bien mon cher maurice a
lancé non pas maintenant a donné les
répliques et si d'aventuré parmi nos
amis quelques quelques-uns veulent
t'aider ne vous en privez pas il s'agit
de donner uniquement des rimes exact où
approchante mais toujours en ac
oui en effet voici le début de ce poème
intitulé fric frac oui c'est normal et
qui commence par j'ai répondu du tac au
tac bien comme une voie à son les bacs
j'ai pris mon manteau et mekla lamit
lalanne ont prononcé non non on n'a que
ça à couy les tenants et toutes mes
pensées en brava oui toi tu sifflets de
l'eau
oui bravo de la fammac mais ton coeur a
soudain fait attaque pas de tactique
soit 4 milliards d'hermine et trois
secondes c'était quoique alors oui bon
10e le dr
accor a oui parce qu'on parlait de l'ofa
bas qui à 81 le poète est parmi nous
voulu mauvais des explications et
attention terminé plus ça va
continuer la pendule afin qu'ils gagnent
car oui j'avais pris mes cliques et ses
claques
j'en ai marre de tout ça
attention attention oui monsieur andré
gaillard j'ai la trouille tu me fous le
pari il fallait bien qu'un jour ça oui
comme un mélo de briques fin d'une
histoire en un acte non attention une
seconde en cinq actes 3 et 2 ans
l'histoire
de sa qualité pourquoi aller l'embrasser
madame propos parce que c'était encore
surtout way le roi ici monsieur gros qui
se termine donc que dans le mid map le
jeu reprend la phrase précédente fin du
mystère que de ça qui se termine dans le
lac oui là qu écouter me chercher
terminé voulu intervenir vous êtes un
poète ne ils doivent se déployer un
terme en fait n'en avait pas fait un
choix donc un bon quand on donne un from
a donc un bon mari non ah bon ah bon un
bond à bondues cadillac noire alors la
c1 trois dates c'était un cognac il en
faut peut-être pour monsieur lavaud bon
qui va maintenant mar 15 secondes
vous l'avez dit quoi
l'alcool
sept mois
[Musique]
bon voilà
où
gaillac ravaillac rama yade tout ça
c'est à cause du saut tiens tiens qui
pousse les astres démoniaque à nous
faire des coups 2 janadi pour que la
machine se détraque il a fallu que tu
m'as non j'ai bien failli devenir
tu n'es plus mon âge mon nom mon nom n'a
une fois voilà on a deux fois on a
découvert trois fois la vague mon
aphrodisiaques quatre des six lotos en
15 secondes voudrez peut-être perdre des
points
la malheureuse en somme et monsieur
drevet
discorde
[Musique]
n'est pas terminée
ma vie devient parent a
jeté les cette attaque a dit yann
compagnon et ton à manama bien des
manières tu es ruse et humetz tu mets
siemens à bonnac et j'ai peur que tu ne
comptes
mois le penseur un peu maniaque louis
dussin livre delà de la monnaie serait
bien que tu rejettes en vaste lac quand
tu veux me vider ton alors adieu mon
très cher jean lannes après
bien sûr ça donc oui très bien fait
remarquer qu'il a mis la [ __ ] mais bon
on va pas dire lucien
tout seul dans ton
lit ne cherche plus tard mois traque tue
point casser la
pas tellement cassé
invités
[Applaudissements]
on va en parler de ce sixième coupe
davis et que vous avez pour l'instant un
parcours sans faute et ce 6ème côté
quand même très important c'est pour ça
que nous pouvons nous y arrêter quelques
instants en effet vous êtes sur la
kasbah donc pour faire 21 cette fameuse
case miracle il faut absolument ferrane
donc j'imagine que votre plaque de 500
francs que vous allez utiliser pour la
dernière fois car maintenant vous l'avez
définitivement tabou sauf si vous perdez
cette ultime épreuve alors cette plaque
vous allez à placer sur quelques havre
le 21 je ne vous le fais pas dire si
vous ne faites pas alain par contre si
vous ne faites pas un arbre vous allez
passer au dessus de la tête de
l'escargot où vous allez quand même
hérité d'une plaque de mille fois pour
aborder votre deuxième tour mais là vous
serez obligé de repartir sur la case
départ car il n'y a que la cap 21 qui
vous autorise à choisir une case pour
repartir alors attention 6e coup de dés
[Musique]
à
dépenser en plus ou en moins à l'origine
ago c'est à dire et bien se veulent cela
veut dire que nous repartons sur la cage
numéro 2 mai
quant à lui mais oui alors là petit
point de détail important en effet tu
lui l'a toujours les tours précise roger
on est reparti de la case départ on a
marqué les deux points que vous venez de
marquer et vous êtes tombé sur une case
déjà lu mais ce qui vous donne droit à
un nouveau coup de dés car les cases
aller mais permettent de rebondir autre
que nous l'aimons mais préalablement la
plaque 2000 francs qui vous appartient
maintenant voilà placé sur quelle case
car maintenant ce n'est plus 500 francs
en plus c'est mille fois en plus à ça
devient passionnant et angoissante on se
croirait au casino faites vos jeux rien
ne va plus on va tenter de rebondir sur
l'a5 c'est vrai elle vous a porté
bonheur au cours du premier tour en
sera-t-il de même au cours du second
tour par conséquent nous appelons tous
1,3 à envoyer le d
[Musique]
encore un
un
bien sûr une case antenne 2 lacasse 3
qui vaut 300 francs mais malheureusement
en ce qui concerne la plaque de 1000
francs que valérie va retirer avec
l'autre des parce que ça devient un
champ de bataille et bien pour l'instant
il n'y ait que 300 francs en jeu pour
cette épreuve qui va d'ailleurs nous
permettre du côté chanson de retrouver
l'extraordinaire succès de richard
sanderson la boum qui aura rapport très
précis avec l'épreuve qui vous attend
demain et bien à tous et à toutes
bonsoir merci de votre
bonne chance pour demain ou un autre
jour sait jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir dans l'âme
on a bon dos car vous êtes seul et vous
allez comprendre pourquoi dans quelques
instants au préalable je crois que bien
que vous soyez seul il est même tout à
fait naturel de faire le point car en
effet nous avons jeté le dès lors de la
dernière mission et nous allons jouer le
coup de ce coup de dés alors ce coude
était local quel était-il mon ami roger
et bien c'est le numéro 3 où se trouve
valérie actuellement et j'en profite
pour vous dire madame que pour l'instant
vous avez fait un sans faute 5 sur 5 que
vos gains sont de 13 cents francs que
vous allez jouer maintenant pour 300
francs et toujours sans frotter à ces
trois
jours précisé qu'au cours de ce premier
tour d'escargots comme vous étiez les
premiers concurrents nous avons été très
coulant mais maintenant nous allons être
infiniment plus rigoureux
l'impression qu'il faut être
je crois que les gens les plus fermes ce
sont les cultivateurs
eh bien par conséquent en effet sur la
casse 3 ou lors de 2ème tour vous n'avez
plus maintenant que combien de côté à
jouer j'ai encore quatre puisque
celui-ci féliciter et vous avez
maintenant une plaque de 1000 francs à
engager les sept plaques de 1000 francs
ou la vie engagée hier et vous ne l'avez
pas gagnée pour l'instant je vais donc
demander à valérie de bien rester
tranquillement sur sept cars numéro
trois et sept cases numéro 3 est bien
madame grebot c'est celle que vous allez
en effet joué sans votre mari enfin pas
tout de suite nous l'avons fait sortir
car au soir de votre première boum boum
nuptiale bien entendu en amour votre
ligne 9 monsieur grosbois du prononcé
des paroles inoubliables vous en
souvenez vous
eh bien écoutez nous vous proposons tant
pis de revivre cet instant le très
pudiquement je mens je m'empresse de le
dire grâce aux quiproquos que nous avons
imaginé en faisant revenir monsieur
globaux qui n'est au courant de rien et
en se contentant de lui remettre son
micro en fait il va s'asseoir là devant
un micro personne n'a le droit de rien
dire et nous allons supposer que pendant
une minute trente tout ce qu'il va dire
c'est ce qu'il nous a dit au cours de
cette merveilleuse nuptiale
alors toutefois comme il y as jeu il
faudra au moins pendant 7 minutes 30 que
sans savoir où il est sans filet ils
émettent au moins dix réflexion s'il
aimait que 8 nov réflexion s'est perdu à
un jeu et vous êtes déjà maintenant dans
le deuxième tour il y a beaucoup
d'argent maintenant alors s'il reste est
en panne vous êtes autorisés à lui faire
des gestes mais on déterre parler parler
parler vous prenez vous avez compris
alors je répète bien pour le mettre dans
l'ambiance tout ce qu'il va dire par
l'ennemi de 30 nous supposons que c'est
ce qu'il vous a dit il y a quelques
années
ce n'est pas plus d'offres on fait
revenir monsieur gros bon sens
applaudissements nourris
[Applaudissements]
si vous confortablement monsieur grebot
vous avez le micro pour une minute
trente qu'est ce que je fais du micro
parmi les trente faut que j'occupe
bon oui je vous raconte des histoires
autour de l'histoire que blaise de quoi
est ce que je pourrais vous parler du
jeu de ce cargo par exemple tout à
l'heure j'étais très déçu parce que je
pensais aller sur le 5 à rebondir et
peut-être
[Musique]
alors avant je vous amuse
bon alors donc je ne suis pas tombé sur
2,5 j'avais sur le 2
il ya un truc et je trouve vous mettez
pas sur la voie du tout
c'est kafkaïen comme situation
bon là c'est moins drôle
alors j'ai continué jusqu'à un coup
alors en passant sur le 5 je pensais
rebondir sur le neuf de l'art bondir sur
le 12 j'ai fait que j'aurais gagner un
maximum d'argent
encore 30 secondes
bon alors plus je gagne l'argent puis je
vous amuser en
rapport avec les sous faut que je trouve
quelque chose
on va écouter je suis loin du temps
encore
parce que j'ai eu des speakerines faire
ça à la télé dit
tellement doué pour occuper l'antenne
au monsieur de repos monsieur gros quoi
qu'il en soit je vous dis tout de suite
vous avez gagné c'était preuve voilà une
comtesse sur 10 réfection je voulais
arrêter si vous n'êtes pas mais malgré
tout je voudrais savoir si vous avez
était intarissable de cette manière au
cours de votre windows parce que tout ce
que vous voulez dire on a supposé que
c'est ce que vous aviez dit
je voulais gagner plus d'argent
il fallait vous faites sur le monde
vous avez pas les réflexions à faire des
amis sur cette business ici si je sais
comment je comprends que madame ait
gardé un très bon souvenir de 7,8
puis s'intéresse à tout
tombé jeudi la numérotée sa femme
d'après
il avait semble-t-il numérotée sa
famille tombée sur la partie
on a quand même pas lui demander à quoi
correspondait cinq ans même
nom mais par contre oui j'ai j'ai
entendu une chose sur un propos de
mariage était dans un restaurant s'ils
sont absolument authentiques dans un
restaurant très sympa il ya des jolies
petites nappes et des chants d'années et
y avait il y avait un monsieur est une
dame à une table et
je sais pas c'était le mari et la femme
j'ai pas pu me voir ils sont engueulés
toute la soirée et
et ça ça commençait à chuter vous voyez
tout est une garce d'image salon tout le
monde s'est arrêté puis tout d'un coup
la femme se lève à lui fait oui eh bien
je vais te dire la vérité tu m'a épousée
parce que je mets de l'argent tu en
voilà la vérité
l'outil prend ça en pleine poire il fait
pour toi qu'est ce que tu dis pour
l'être ça y est pas pour les petits
tienne tu m'épouser parce que jamais
d'argent voilà la vérité mais fait du
n'importe quoi je ne t'ai pas y poser
parce que tu avais de l'argent je t'ai
épousée parce que j'en avais pas
j'espère
anglaise ce bulletin est valable excès
c'est pas bon parce que vous avez parlé
d'argent il a dit vous faut-il que je
gagne beaucoup d'argent il très
intéressé alors moi je vais parler de
mon mariage c'est à dire c'est que c'est
ma femme est très heureuse depuis mon
mariage tous les matins je la porte son
café au lit le matin est la plus calme
moudre
à côté la seule histoire que blaise dos
pu raconter c'est l'histoire d'un mari
qui se laisse pas faire il entre dans le
bistrot c'est ça entre dans le bistrot
où sont tous ses copains il leur dit mes
enfants ce soir c'est vous qui êtes tous
cocus je vais me coucher avec ma femme
eh bien nous allons quand même
maintenant prendre connaissance du score
après votre brillante performance plus
gros pot minutes enregistré vous pourrez
vous rappeler comme ça aux nuits de noël
ou alors dans les veillées ce que vous
avez dit à madame gros soir de la nuit
alors c'est bien pour l'instant 1600
francs il s'y sent rentrera sans faute
alors que nous avons six épreuves alors
écoutez je crois que maintenant nous
allons laisser l'inventeur de ce jeu
parfaitement tard discret
vous raconter comment il voit la fin de
cette émission olivier est bien pour la
fin d'émission jeu réservé de belles
surprises à mon camarade de classe de
lycée nous étions et voilà quinze ans au
lycée pasteur ensemble sur art jugnot il
est également il est sorti en même temps
que monsieur grebot il est aussi dans le
secret ne sais pas ce qui va se passer
on va le faire revenir et on va voir sur
un comédien professionnel est ce que ça
peut donner gérard jugnot à toi de jouer
[Applaudissements]
cela dit j'ai peur qu'on
il part bien servi
oui
olabe à
blaye anti âge là
est un piège eux oui
c'est avec
[Musique]
sachez madame
il n'est pas sectaire
ah oui d'accord
le va jouer ça
le boeuf de n'a pas joué
quelqu'un peut dire quelque chose là
dessus il peut il m'aider là
je trouve que j'ai un tempérament
fonceur
j'ai peur qu'il y ait quelque chose de
sexuel derrière
un pas reprendre seconde accord il faut
qu'on se dépêche là bas
je comprends
bon je comprends je crois
qu est ce que je pourrais dire comme
cochonneries
[Rires]
c'est peut-être me déshabiller un petit
peu c'est une histoire comme ça eh bien
mon cher girard histoires comme ça va
vous mettre au courant parce que
maintenant nous allons prendre congé de
nos amis nous voulions finir sur cette
note ou combien sympathique et amusante
riz de lait on a été beaucoup moins
rigoureux avec fougue avec monsieur
globaux tout à l'heure et vous avez en
effet un peu de finition c'est bon mais
olivier lejeune l'inventeur du jeu va
vous prendre après l'émission pour vous
raconter tout
nouvel essai ou encore monsieur madame
robot nous rappelons que deux que nous
allons les retrouver dans la prochaine
émission pour qu'elles coûtent des
rejets le 7e et vous ne serez plus qu'à
quatre côtés du grand chelem alors
serrons les douars bonne bonne bonne
part coup bonne suite de parcours aller
au revoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]